التقت المبعوثه الامريكيه للنيجر فيكتوريا
نولاند في نيام قاده الانقلاب من دون ان
تنتقي رئيسه او الرئيس المنقلب عليهم كان
ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولد في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات
ما هدف زياره مسؤوله امريكيه بهذا المستوى
الى نيامي في هذا التوقيت ما مغزى هذا
الاهتمام الدولي والاقليمي الكبير بما
يجري في النيجر ما المسارات المحتمله
للازمه في النيجر على ضوء انقسام دول
جواره حيال خيار التدخل العسكري
ان الرغبه اداره بايتن هي كانت مناقشه
المناقشه مع قاده الانقلاب لمعرفه ما هي
النواياهم مع التركيز طبعا على محاوله
اعاده الرئيس المنتخب الديمقراطيه
بطريقه سلميه على ما نعمل في اللحظه
الراهنه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
استلمت زمام المبادره بالنسبه الى هذا
الملف
اعودت بزوم وهو ما تعرفه السيده نولاند ان
عوده بازوم صعب للغايه لذلك يجب النظر في
الظروف التي تسمح بالتفاوض مع العسكريين
من دون القول ان هذا الانقلاب قد نجحت
زياره اقامه
مفيده جدا وهي مفيده لانني اعتقد ان اكويس
كانوا متسرعين جدا بالتهديد بالتدخل
العسكري هي لمحاوله اجراء محادثات
دبلوماسيه والتاكد انه قبل تدخل عسكري
هناك حوار حقيقي وتبادل الكلام حقيقي على
امل
يتجنب التدخل العسكري هل هذا هو الحال ام
لا علينا ان ننتظر لنرى قامت به السيده
نولد لارادت ان تفتح هذا الخط الاتصال مع
العسكريين كي لا تاتي مجموعه باضافه الى
التواجد الامريكي العسكري في النيجر الا
يتاثر كهذا التهديد وبعد انتهاء
المهدث الانذار التي قدمها اصبح من واضح
ان بحاجه الى
الانسحاب قليلا هو ان هذه الزياده السيد
مهمه وقد حسب رايي منعت التدخل العسكري
هناك تراكم نحن نتحدث عن خامس انقلاب
عسكري في اقل من ثلاث سنوات لذلك هذا
التراكم ادى الى تلك النتيجه
لديها مفهوم وعدم الاهتمامه وتحسس
والقضايا الهامه في النيجر اما الولايات
المتحده فهي لا لا تدعم الانقلاب الولايات
المتحده
تفهم
مركزيه واهميه
النيجر في مكافحه الارهاب والولايات
المتحده تستخدم اسلوبا اكثر نضجا بالقول
دعونا نجري حديثا دعونا نتبادل الكلام
لنصل الى وضع يكون الجميع في فائزون هناك
صعوبه بالغه في التعبير عن الموقف في
فرنسا اليوم فرنسا متشدده في موقفها نعم
لم تبدا فرنسا بمفاوضات تفتح قنوات
الاتصال مع المجلس العسكري السلوك الذي
تقوم به فرنسا هو الذي يعرف كل منطقه الى
دينامكيه جديده فرنسا التي تخشى اعاده
السيناريو الذي حصل في مالي
ووصول روسيا وتمدد النفوذ الروسي في تلك
المنطقه ودفع فرنسا خارج
[موسيقى]
انه من وجهه نظر الولايات المتحده فهم
يتمنون او يريدون التجنب التدخل العسكري
من قبل اكواس او اي دوله اخرى باي كلفه
لذلك فيه خطر تصعيده الازمه وايصال الى
دول اخرى المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول الغرب
افريقيا رفعت السقف وليس لديها القدرات
لتتدخل ولا يمكنها ان تتدخل من دون دعم
على الاقل من خلال الدعم الاستخباري
ولوجستيه من قبل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وفرنسا ما تريد حقا الولايات
المتحده هو تجنب وحصول حرب اما بقياده
لاكواس او بقياده
باريس او اي طرف اخر بل يبدون فقط العوده
النظام الدستوري حتى لو كان ذلك لا يعني
بالضروره عوده بازون الى السلطه اعتقد ان
التدخل العسكري يبتعد وليست بالفكره
المنطقيه والجميع يعرف ذلك يعتقد انه
يمكننا ان نتنفس الصعداء لان تاجيل
امكانيه الدخول في هذا الحل ادى الى اراحه
الاطراف ان القرار فيما يتعلق بك كيف تحكم
النيجر نفسها هو فقط مسؤوليه الشعب
النيجيري ولا غيرهم